hey guys this is my tutorial on how to
just hear it
now this is a website here that speaks
for itself i'm going to open up
apple's safari web browser
and i have a bookmark here so i'll post
a link in the description but it's it's
relatively simple this is just called
justherit.com
www.justhera.com
so let me
give me a second here
yes please
all right
open your web browser and type in
justherit.com
and the only bad part is occasionally it
does do this and it freezes at ten
percent let's try firefox this time
uh basically it speaks for itself
um it's a website where you can for free
hear any song that you want any song
um and it will stream um online which
does take a little bit of cpu
but um it's extremely easy no login no
username no email just type in a song
you wanna hear
so that's a song i want to hear right
now so let's load that and just like
that we're streaming
so i'll just pause that you can hear it
streams and it's really good quality for
some odd reason
so i use this um i use this site all the
time if i'm if i just hear a song that i
won't if i hear a song on the radio and
i can't quite think i'll just type in
some lyrics heard from it like
i just i just hear some notes from it
and bam i click on it and
and it plays it streams it's really
really good quality
and i gotta go but i just gotta say i
highly recommend this website it's
really smooth um and really fast so uh
justherit.com it'll be in the
description bookmark it trust me you'll
love it
so um thanks for watching guys